[Music]
howdy everyone hopefully you're all here
to see continuous delivery best
practices with Jenkins and gke my name
is Vic Iglesias I'm a Solutions
Architect with Google my twitter handle
is there if you want to heckle me
digitally I am a huge fan of Jenkins and
I've been using Jenkins for somewhere on
the order of 5 or 6 years now I've
broken Jenkins a lot have made Jenkins
do some things that Jenkins did not want
to do and in that I've learned some
things and then I joined Google and I'm
kind of the guy who makes these best
practices kind of documentation for
Jenkins at Google my co-workers have
picked up on this and they have created
a set of memes about how much I love
Jenkins like this one yo dawg i heard
you like jenkins
so I wrote a Jenkins plugin to launch
Jenkins pods to monitor all your Jenkins
jobs they continually come out with
these heckling me about all of my
Jenkins solutions and how much I love
Jenkins so today we're gonna do a brief
overview of Jenkins how many people use
Jenkins yeah I usually get about a 50%
but I'd figure that'd be more like 80 or
90 here how many people use Jenkins on
GCP alright and how about on gke okay
cool
so we'll do brief overview most of you
guys know what we're talking about here
then we're gonna talk about the Jenkins
journey I'm sure we've all been here
before where you start in one place and
you end up molding a Jenkins
installation over time and we're gonna
talk about what that looks like and then
we're gonna talk about how to implement
the end state when you've gotten Jenkins
in a good state and it's scalable and it
runs well and your team is happy once we
go through that we'll talk about how to
integrate Jenkins and spinnaker in order
to do continuous delivery all right so a
brief overview what is Jenkins this
Jenkins guy we've been talking about
it's a build server you can trigger or
schedule jobs or processes and run your
automation steps at some point somebody
has scripted something and they want to
run it in a shared environment or run it
on
commit Jenkins gives you a really easy
way to do that we also have a pluggable
architecture which is a lot of the
reason why chenkin z' is used by a lot
of the folks in this room it can capture
a lot of the use cases that we have and
various tools that we need to integrate
into our CI and CD processes how many
people use Jenkins plug-ins how many
people use more than five Jenkins
plug-ins more than 10 20
oh all right we should talk after the
Jenkins plug-in ecosystem is what
enables us to use Jenkins but also has
its downside so you have to keep track
of the plugins they're mostly open
source you have to know the quality of
the plug-in it has to have good
documentation it has to have a good
upgrade strategy so with every you know
blessing there is a little bit of a
curse in these bless in these plugins
one of the nice things about Jenkins is
it runs on the JVM and so does its agent
so we can register notes on various
distro so you can have linux agents
which is what mostly i've used in the
past Windows agents or Mac agents how
many people are using Windows or Mac
with Jenkins yeah cool so that's what
we're talking about here so when someone
asked me what do I do for my CI CD
process I just sprinkle a little Jenkins
on it that's not always the case but a
lot of the times we can start there so
what is a Jenkins journey look like well
Daewon Genesis right people have been
running scripts on their computers
there's some you know scripts that are
clobbering each other's behaviors and
you decide that you need a shared place
to run these based off of git commits
which would be a really nice way to do
things so you find a machine somewhere
it's probably in the corner it's like a
Raspberry Pi and you install Java on it
it takes up all the memory you install
Jenkins you load up all your
dependencies on there for whatever you
need for your build you might need a
special version of node or go or some
test library or something like that and
then you start running your scripts in
the shared build server so you're stoked
it's better than everybody else
running in their laptops and what you
end up with is this one Jenkins master
node that has the Jenkins JVM process in
there a build executor that's a process
that's actually running your builds
and all your bill dependencies in there
additionally you have the Jenkins home
file system how many people are familiar
with Jenkins home this it's really
comfortable it's our home
so in in your home you have your
configuration and that's the
configuration of all your plugins of
your Jenkins server itself you also have
build artifacts so things that you're
storing after your build completes that
might be some sort of binary or things
like that the other thing that runs in
that Jenkins home is your build
workspaces so your build workspaces is
that scratch space that your build gets
to clone your repo and do temporary
things in that build process great so
your Stoke people are sharing this
environment they're triggering builds
off of commits or scheduling builds but
then you see this right how many people
have seen this Jenkins yeah yeah it's
painful so something has gone wrong in
your Jenkins installation it may not be
scaling appropriately maybe you ran out
of resources on that raspberry pi so
what do you do you scale to more nodes
so you take your build agents and you
run them somewhere else so your builds
run separately this is great you've
moved your build executors process out
of your Jenkins master you've moved your
build dependencies into those Jenkins
nodes and your build workspaces so now
your Jenkins master has some room to
breathe so this is a great next step
having a static fleet distributed from
your Jenkins master but again the build
is breaking and this time it is because
we need more disk those build artifacts
that were on arm our Jenkins master have
filled up our Jenkins home file system
so now we decide to start using object
storage to move our artifacts off of
that Jenkins master I think you should
probably use Google Cloud Storage for
reasons I won't to tell you about but
you know you think you'd want all of
this storage to move to any other place
other than your Jenkins masters and
there's various plugins that can make
this happen how many people are using an
artifact plugin yeah ok
so now you're happy you're scaling well
Jenkins master is healthy and happy but
you're developers are coming to you and
saying that they need competing versions
of dependencies on these build agents so
now you've got the problem of figuring
out how do i label these nodes how do I
get people to run the right bills on the
right systems but instead you decide to
move to containerization so you can run
each of your builds in containers and
you get the benefit of being able to
give developers exactly the dependencies
that they want and you won't clobber
each other's dependencies so now
developers are happy they have more
control
next they come to you with the next
problem yes we have more control this is
great but we're poking around the
Jenkins UI too much in order to
configure our our jobs so we want a way
to do this in source code and the way to
do this in Jenkins is using the Jenkins
pipeline plug-in and creating your
Jenkins file next to your source code so
now developers can commit code that
changes the test process or the build
process and the source code at the same
time and they're really happy how many
people are using Jenkins pipeline yes we
should get that to everyone relatively
soon so that's great and you put
pipelines everywhere you can have your
happy little pipeline world in Jenkins
land and everybody is happier that they
have control over their build process
next your CFO comes up to you and says
hey you know it's looking like we're
spending quite a bit of money on this CI
process do you think you could tune that
down in any way so you poke around and
you realize oh I know what to do between
8 & 6 I have a lot of builds running but
as soon as developers leave and go home
there's no bills running on all my build
agents so you look into some way to do
auto scaling agents so that when you
kick off a build and there's no agent
available its provisioned for you has
all your dependencies in there and then
when no bills are running it terminates
itself and there are various ways to do
this there is a GCE plug-in that allow
you to do this with VMs you can also use
kubernetes plugin to do this on Jukka
eat talk a little bit more about that
great so you're moving along at a pretty
good clip here
nowaday 4:12 comes along and each team
is competing for which plugins are the
right plugins to have in their Jenkins
installation right
not every plug-in is compatible with
every other pilot plug-in there is a
dependency chain there so they say we
want to have our own Jenkins
installations for our team or for our
sets of teams so you figure out a way to
make reproducible Jenkins installations
and give them exactly the plugins that
they want so you've made everybody
really happy you have a scalable system
now you're managing multiple Jenkins but
since they auto scale and they have
enough resources and don't over over
provision resources for them you're
you're you're feeling like good as it as
an administrator ok so that was you know
what you need to do to be happy with
Jenkins and at scale but how do you get
there today first you have to figure out
how to deploy Jenkins right and in the
previous slide I showed using helm to
deploy Jenkins one of the nice things
how we people have know what helm is
good amount so I'll talk a little bit
about home helm is a package manager for
kubernetes it allows you to package up
applications and then install them the
packages in this context are called
charts and charts are ways to define
what comes with an application there is
a Jenkins home chart in the community
and it provides a lot of the same
defaults that you would expect for a
Jenkins installation to be scalable and
secure so we leverage this in order to
create our installations of Jenkins one
of the nice things about this tom chart
is it allows you to define declaratively
exactly the plugins you want to have in
your installation which is super useful
so what does this look like on the left
here we have the installation command
for Jenkins helm install stable Jenkins
and then a values file stable is the
name of the chart repository that this
chart is coming from Jenkins is
obviously the name of the chart that
we're installing and then I pass it this
values file and this is my configuration
on the right here you can see the
configuration that I'm passing it I have
a list of plugins I have some CPU and
memory configuration and I have some
Java ops
who knows what people are gonna throw in
there but that always comes up the next
thing that I do is I disable the default
agent configuration because I want my
developers in their Jenkins files to
define this and I'll show how this is
possible later the next few are the
persistence the size of the Jenkins home
again I don't need a huge disk but I'd
like to have some space in there for
Jenkins to to have its configurations
and so forth and the other two options
the network policy in the our back are
some security defaults that you can get
out of the box cool so what do I get by
installing this home chart into a
kubernetes engine cluster first you can
use kubernetes engines auto scaling node
pools which allows you to provision new
pods and kubernetes engine will add new
nodes to your cluster as needed next we
get into that world automatically where
we have all of our debt build
dependencies defined by containers that
is just a default mode that you're going
to use when you're running on kubernetes
engine the next thing you get is
ephemeral workspaces and this is
something that was really important when
I was running CI systems a few years ago
is to have a clean workspace for every
built so this is going to be guaranteed
for you because your docker container is
going to come up do do its work and then
that workspace is going to be cleared
out so you don't have any cruft coming
in from other builds the next thing you
can have is preemptable nodes
preemptable nodes allow you to save 70%
of the cost of your nodes but there is a
trade-off at any point those nodes could
be deep provisioned or terminated and
they will only last up to 24 hours so if
you have some builds that can be
restarted this can save you quite a bit
of money out of the gate what we see is
customers running half of their notes as
preemptable and another half as regular
nodes so they can always have capacity
for builds the next thing that running
on kubernetes engine gives you is the
ability to apply soft and hard resource
limits so if I say that a bill needs at
least a gigabyte of RAM I can say that
it also must cannot have cannot use more
than 2 gigs of RAM so I can set
specifically how much resources these
bills are going to use
as they share a note cool so how do i
define these agents in my jenkins file
and this is something that I advocate
for because you're giving over that
control over to the developer right
you're saying you tell me how you want
your build spec to look you have various
containers that you can run in here and
as you can see here I'm just defining a
kubernetes pod that means that I can
define multiple containers if I need
them and separate my build dependencies
in that way and that's really useful the
other thing that I'm doing down here is
wrapping my shell commands in this
example go test with the container
markup here and that allows me to say
which container each of these commands
should run in so really you've handed
over all of the control of the the build
process to the developer in source code
which is really awesome so now that
we've given them control over their
environment and the built dependencies
that are in there we have to give them
away to actually build those images the
easiest way to do that would be to use
Google Cloud build which allows you to
create a trigger based off of source
code then we'll build your image and
then upload that to Google container
registry so a really streamlined process
for them to change their their build
dependencies cool next we said we want
to leave our artifacts off of the
Jenkins master so we're going to install
the Google Cloud Storage plugin we're
going to upload a DCP iam service
account key that has access to the
projects that we want to upload our
artifacts to and then we're going to use
those in our build process usually as a
post build step to upload our artifacts
to Google Cloud Storage this can be done
in the UI or also as a pipeline step
cool so now let's get into the demo side
of that and we're going to demo a
developer updating their their image and
then pushing a new build out all right
so if we could go over to the demo
laptop yes I am running Linux on the
desktop yes it was extremely difficult
to get this to show up on the screen
all right um so let's go to some code
here it like so this is my developer
test image here
and really it's just a docker file that
has golang and a couple of my
dependencies in there great so let's say
that I wanted to use the golang RC built
from gulling 111 instead of 110 I'm
gonna go ahead and commit that all right
going 110 111 I'm gonna tag it and push
that tag and the commit cool so when I
push this cloud build is going to detect
that I've created a new commit and it's
gonna start building my artifact great
so really I didn't have to do much in
order to make that happen I could
basically ignore the fact that it did
happen at all and just start adding that
configuration of that base image to my
Jenkins file so in my Jenkins file for
my app I am defining the the pod that I
want to run for my build and in here I
have my test image that I just showed
you and I'm going to change from version
six oh just seven no which is the one I
just built and that's really all I
wanted to change at this point so now as
a developer I can change my build setup
relatively easy and I'll just make that
change to my pipeline file and commit
and push that cool all right
and once I push that it's gonna go ahead
and be detected by Jenkins I'm actually
just gonna kick a build off myself
oops damn another time let's see this
here my port forwarding wasn't working
let's see so let's kick that off again
all right and so now I've got my build
running in inside of Jenkins and let's
see what this this Jenkins file does so
in here I have my pod definition I'm
defining to two containers one for my
test image and that's just really for
running go test and then one for g-cloud
and so I don't have to have
one mega uber image for every single
thing that I want to have I can
compartmentalize these dependencies and
then use them in independently and
Jenkins is going to mount my workspace
into each of these containers so I don't
have to worry about moving or mounting
weird workspaces anywhere so in my test
image I run go test and then after it's
done and the tests have passed which I'm
sure we're really a good test I'm going
to just run Google container g-cloud
container builds submit in order to
build an image from my docker file so
let's take a look at what's going on
here
so here I've had my build started we can
see my commit message here Jenkins
provisioned a pod for me and then
started running my tests and then the
belt so if I look in my kubernetes
commands I can see that my test pod was
created so that's great and now it's
being terminated once the build has
completed and that's because we had our
image built and pushed so our new image
has been deployed and we're happy cool
so that's the process of a developer
kind of owning that CI process for
themselves cool so let's go back to the
slides and we'll keep moving along so we
talked about the CI part of Jenkins on
gke
now we'll talk about CD continuous
delivery or continuous deployment this
is going to be your best friend this is
kind of the best tool we have today and
what we're going to use throughout this
demo to talk about how to deploy to
kubernetes from Jenkins how many people
are using cube control apply to deploy
yeah okay so the first thing you're
going to ask when you're using a cube
control apply or anything like this is
which cluster should I be deploying to
and in order to understand that we first
should understand how cube config works
so the cube config defines a bunch of
clusters and that's a name a server URL
and some CA data it also defines some
users and ways to authenticate to those
clusters and it combines those two
things into what's called a context
and the context is which tells us
definitively who who should we should
authenticate with and which cluster to
authenticate to within your cube config
you're going to have multiple of these
contexts lined up and one of them is
going to be flagged as your current
context so that's going to be the
default context that when you've run
cube control with no other flags is
going to be used cool so now that we
know that how do we use cube config
inside of Jenkins well they have a handy
plugin again called the kubernetes CLI
plugin so in order to use this we're
gonna upload our cube config as a
Jenkins administrator as a Jenkins
credential and then within our
pipeline's we can use that Jenkins
credential with this with cube config
wrapping block around our commands so
that is what sets the context for each
of these commands that we run in that
block so here I have two different
stages one that deploys to canary one
that applies to production and I can
choose which cluster it is by setting
the context name in each of those with
config blocks cool so now that we know
where to deploy code to how do we know
how to roll out the code so for example
we could do a Bluegreen deployment how
many folks do Bluegreen deployments so a
Bluegreen deployment in kubernetes with
without bringing Jenkins into the mix
you would have a service and a
deployment and that service would map to
the deployment based on the labels so
here I have a label app and a label
version and and those apply to my
deployment so now it's sending traffic
to the blue version in order to bring on
my green version I would deploy it with
a different set of labels so here I have
apt my app still but I've changed the
version to green so the service is no
longer mapping to that is not mapping to
that deployment but when I do want to
map it to that deployment I can switch
the label on the service and do a
Bluegreen deployment that way now if I
want to switch back I just can switch
the labels on the service so that makes
it easy to do Bluegreen and then roll
back quickly alright so we haven't
talked about Jenkins there what would
this look like in a pipeline
well first we would want to build an
image you get an artifact out there then
we want to create a new deployment which
there are many ways to do
and grab a knock and all kinds of things
to get the right build image into your
deployment once we do deploy that new
deployment we want to make sure we
verify it somehow and what does that
mean well some some things you could do
if there's probably more is check that
the rollout has actually completed so
you can use the Q control rollout status
the deployment command and that will
tell you yes I think that I have done
everything that I need to do in order to
make sure that this deployment rolls out
the next thing you can do is check that
all your pods are healthy and running
for some period of time after so you
might run into a situation where you've
deployed a deployment and the pods come
up healthy but then crash after some
amount of time so you might want to
decide how long that real healthy period
is going to be for you and you can also
define some of this stuff inside of the
kubernetes manifests cool so now we've
verified that our deployment has
succeeded as far as we know now we can
shift traffic to it using a similar
mechanism and then again we're gonna
verify that once we switch traffic over
our service is happy so how are we gonna
do this we can use Q control endpoints
to make sure that pods are actually
mapped to our service and this would be
something to to verify that your
labeling scheme is correct you may have
put some bad labels in that deployment
and now your service doesn't know where
to send traffic the next thing you can
do is go one level up on the load
balancing side and if you've had any
HTTP load balancers provisioned with an
ingress resource you can use Q control
get ingress to make sure your backends
are still healthy
once those are complete and you know
your service is mapped to a load
balancer appropriately you can start to
run tests maybe it's cute control run
maybe you're hitting it from outside but
actually verify that your service is
doing what it's supposed to be doing in
some way shape or form if these things
fail you can roll back to the previous
deployment at this point if everything
succeeds then you delete your previous
deployment and move along your merry way
great so that's one way to deploy which
is Bluegreen how many people do rolling
update a good majority your application
has to be a understanding of a rolling
update but it's a
great way to deploy in the default way
to deploy within kubernetes we will
bring up new pods for you and tear down
your old ones one by one you do have
some flexibility in how you roll out
when you do that strategy and your
options here are how many pods should I
should you bring up at a time and then
how many pods can be unavailable at any
given time these two can can be used
with either percentages or absolute
values and I think for for larger
deployments you're going to want to do
percentages for things that are
relatively static you might be able to
just get away with using a number of
pods cool so what can I do further to
make this deployment robust one thing is
the readiness and liveness probes that
you attach to your pods
how many people use readiness probes
this is probably the most important
thing you can do to have a robust
deployment process what is a readiness
probe the readiness probe is a way for
kubernetes to ask your app if it should
send traffic to it and that's a really
key place it's where your application
and the infrastructure meet and you have
to have something that is very
indicative of your services health
responding here so for example you can
have an HTTP request some people have a
health endpoint you can have all kinds
of different things that are checked in
this endpoint and if for example your
application needs to reach out to a
database make sure that that database is
there before you respond that you're
ready to receive traffic so you can
think of all of the different
dependencies in your application that
would need to be there for you to have a
really healthy request or healthy
response to a request that came in this
is really something really important to
think about and there's a lot of tuning
you can do to get the right readiness
probe in place the next thing is
graceful termination so when your pod is
going to get taken down by kubernetes
it's gonna send your pod and your
containers a cig term signal and you
have to react to that signal because
it's basically kubernetes again the
application and the infrastructure
coming together to say I'm gonna tear
you down you need to
stop doing what you're doing and make
sure that all your requests get flushed
for example so one example of a good way
to handle the the sig term when you
receive that sig term make sure that you
turn off or you know disable your
readiness probe so that kubernetes stops
sending you traffic if you're gonna be
torn down
you probably shouldn't have any more
traffic coming at you well after that
point you can start to finish up any
connections you have and then terminate
yourself gracefully one of the options
you have here is the termination grace
period seconds and that's going to allow
you to define how long of time you need
in order to tear down great so we've
talked about a lot of different things
that you can do in your CD process
using Jenkins and queue control apply in
your pipeline files and now we'll look
at a different approach which is using
spinnaker spinnaker is a multi cloud
continuous delivery platform Jenkins
started out as a CI server it can run
anything that you need it to run
spinnaker started out as fully focused
on continuous delivery only how to get
code an artifact from one place to
another
so if continuous delivery is this long
chain of events
Jenkins is extremely good at this part
and spinnaker is extremely good at the
next part which is actually getting your
code rolled out into various
environments doing manual judgements
based on whether you know certain
metrics are looking correct and so this
is what we're gonna see today there are
some interfaces between Jenkins and
spinnaker and the two main ones are that
spinnaker pipelines can be triggered by
a Jenkins job so as a Jenkins job
completes successfully spinnaker will
check it and potentially take some
information from that build result and
then start its pipeline with that
information the other thing that you can
do with spinnaker and Jenkins is have
spinnaker run Jenkins job in the middle
of a pipeline so you may have a rollout
process that requires some sort of
performance test in the middle and that
really is orchestrated or run by Jenkins
so you can have a spinnaker do a rollout
of a deployment
run your your integration test or your
performance test using Jenkins and then
continue your rollout so you don't
always have to pick all of them up all
at once
so in spinnaker you have the ability to
define these triggers and the pipeline
trigger UI looks like this you define
which spinnaker or which Jenkins master
you want to point at which job you want
to run from inside that or which a job
you want to detect a change on in from
that just been a Jenkins master and then
potentially a properties file and so the
properties file is a way to communicate
information from Jenkins into spinnaker
and that follows the Java properties
file format which is key equals value
and so you can pass if you create this
file inside of your build process and
archive it then spinnaker can pick it up
and use this information in its pipeline
to configure various steps the other
thing that I said that spinnaker could
do is kick off a Jenkins job in the
middle of a pipeline so the way that
this looks is let's say I have a Jenkins
job that has these parameters in
spinnaker as part of my pipeline I can
create a stage that will pull in this
Jenkins job and show me those parameters
it'll bring up the defaults as well but
then I can parameterize them with
information from my spinnaker pipeline
so these two interplay pretty well and
so you don't have to you know give up
Jenkins in order to use spinnaker or
vice-versa so now we'll go through what
this process actually looks like end to
end with Jenkins doing most live to see
I work and then spinnaker picking up
from there once an artifact is built so
if we could switch over to the laptop
once I log
alright ok so here I mentioned I had a
web app
sample app here we're gonna do a green
blue deployment just to be a little
different
our UI is green some product manager
comes in with their hair on fire and
says Green is no longer in we need this
to be blue ASAP developer make it happen
so I use my awesome coding skills to
hack HTML and I go to my green change
that to blue wherever I see it and I am
pumped I don't know what this error is
we're gonna go it may be my downfall in
this whole demo thing but we'll see
alright so I commit this make it blue
and I'm gonna push it and then we're
gonna follow this along a little bit as
it goes through our process so again I'm
just gonna kick this off so we get a
build ASAP awesome so first thing that's
gonna happen is Jenkins says hey I don't
have any pods available for you I need
to provision one so we should see in
here that Jenkins is gonna start
provisioning me a pod cool so it
provisions me a pod just for that build
and it's gonna run through our procedure
which is again to run our tests well
first check out our source code then run
our tests and then do a build with cloud
build and then in cloud build I'll just
show you the trigger that I've set up oh
I don't have a trigger I'm just building
them directly in in spinnaker I have a
trigger here that is waiting for changes
to GCR so any image that comes in into a
particular GC our repository it's going
to kick off this pipeline and then I
tell it that I'm gonna use this that
docker image that that got pushed as
part of a pipeline step so in that
pipeline I deploy my back-end and deploy
my front end and I tell it yeah alright
now I have a static artifact which I
just entered text but I could pull this
from a repository or a GCS bucket and I
tell it that I want to take this these
artifacts or this
Manifest and replace this image that's
in here with the one that came in from
the the docker build so here I have my
bills running and you'll see in here
that spinnaker is doing a lot of those
things that we scripted out in our
pipeline for us it's monitoring the
deployment it's making sure that things
actually get to the state that they want
to get to spinnaker actually understands
the infrastructure behind it right so it
knows that what a pot is and what it
means for the pod to be healthy and so
forth so that's what's running in the
background here let's see this there we
go so now it's succeeded it's actually
pushed out our change and we should have
blue and that error didn't mean anything
so yay so so so if we could go back to
slides that's a very simplified view of
something you could do spinnaker can do
much more complex deployments to
multiple clusters do manual judgments
all kinds of stuff but I just wanted to
see you see the connective tissue
between these pieces and you can
extrapolate forward with your
imagination as to what your build
process should be in your deployment
process should be okay thick so you just
gave me all this information you're
probably gonna watch this on YouTube
again to probably dig into some of the
pieces but what can you do today to
start getting your hands dirty with some
of these processes I mentioned earlier
that I've written a lot about Jenkins
and gke and so I'll show you a few of
the things that I've written
first was the Jenkins on gke continuous
delivery tutorial and this is really a
multi using multiple branches to define
environments and then having Jenkins
push those environments out into
container engine and that is available
online there that's Jenkins on gke
continuous delivery I also wrote one
with just a container builder or cloud
built as it's been renamed and that is
continuous delivery with spinnaker on
compute engine or kubernetes engine so
that's if you want to use spinnaker and
cloud build for your CI NCD process but
then there are some folks who are not
ready to adopt kubernetes yet and for
those folks I have the Jenkins on GCE
tutorial and
I think the easiest way to get going
with those built agents that I said
before that automatically auto scale and
get provisioned when you need them this
you you can just basically take your
even on Prem Jenkins master enable the
Jenkins GCE plug-in and get going with
distributed builds on GCE so a really
easy way to on board and that is it
thank you so much for listening to
[Applause]
[Music]
you